i saw him out there
when's the last time you bought a camera
early 2012 i bought the canon 7d
super sketchy craigslist deal
like i ordered this thing early last
week and then there's a big storm on the
east coast i forget what the storm's
name is storm for stormy i got my lenses
though so uh that's cool you know i can
look at them
so these are the lenses i bought they're
those uh rokinon cine ds lenses you
actually got the delivery well i got my
lenses i don't have the camera yet dude
you got so many lenses so i can just
like pretend
say cheese dude i've heard so many great
things about rokinon lenses they're
super affordable and uh from all the
time
[Applause]
[Music]
it's only been a week but it feels like
a month how's lifeline great tonight we
have a 3am shoot tomorrow we have a 3 am
shoot the next day we have a 3 a.m shoot
the next day we have a 3 am shoot do you
mean it goes until 3am or it starts at
3am it goes till 3. so you've been
shooting for one week of 8 or 9 so far
eight an eighth of the way done actually
i'm eight point
an eighth no hold on
i'm like um
nine and eight ten sixty fourths of the
way done
okay
because you can in the days yeah
recording you may have seen these videos
out there where celebrities will
peel off little stickers on google
search boards that have like their it's
like they go through the top google
searches for their name and reveal what
funny auto complete answers there are
well we thought that would be funny to
do
more broadly because we're not that
famous so let's do it let's do it how am
i how am i a clown can we just search
that one really quick how am i a clown
yeah i mean this is like
did you get that
last thing
i'm a clown
mclaren god
there's another youtube video ugly am i
ugly dude a quiz wait do it
how how ugly are you okay
uh you guys talk to you yes do you have
many friends do you have any friends i'd
say what are from what are friends i'd
say some do you do people ask you for
pictures i ask you for pictures
sometimes yeah let's take a look a few
how many boyfriends have you had none
are there many broken mirrors in your
house uh do you feel ugly no like what
am i am i supposed to feel pretty feel
pretty okay yeah i guess so when you
walk down the street do people look at
you weird sometimes do people call you
ugly uh
when i dress weird do you dress in out
of fashion clothes you dress in out of
fashion clothes i mean but that is in
fashion okay who needs fashion all right
let's see how ugly you are okay
man you are ugly i advise you do not
leave the house without a paper bag on
your head
there you go flip that around
there it
is how many lenses have you ever opened
for my canon 7d i owned that 18 to 55
kit lens the really bad one and then my
favorite lens though is that ninety
dollar nifty 50. dude plastic that was
my primary lens for like a year and a
half no dude you know that movie torture
that you did effects on like that one
before we even worked here so yeah we
shot that whole film basically on that
nifty 50 lens and it looks freaking
awesome before ren and i even worked
here i hired him to do vfx for like a
short film that i did with brett and uh
yeah that was that was in early 2012.
yeah that was five years ago ren was
struggling with doing tracer rounds
of course you want to bring that of
course
i was like it was a combination of
there's so many and i was like but i
don't want to do like a hundred
different traces and they're not that
easy to be fair i probably wasn't paying
you that much so
so what's cool about cinema lenses
compared to photography lenses is that
one you have your focus ring with a
focused gear and then also you have a
manual aperture gear as well which lets
you manually dial in the aperture on the
lens as opposed to inside the camera so
you don't get that clicky like you guys
will probably notice in the vlogs when
we go in or out of a building see mike
and i like hitting that exposure dial
really hard here click click click click
when you're on set a sound guy can pick
that up if you're clicking around oh
wait i am the camera why
am i
good at bed
okay
all right when it comes to sex positions
you
tend to stick to a couple favorites
you know
wow you're having sex with a new guy
what are you thinking about
there's not so much thinking he's doing
he has no plan all right so honestly how
do you feel about your body when you're
having sex
with that question one question is that
gray hair
guide him pretend it's good or shift a
bit
probably just pretend it's good dude
dang nick
where's your mind when you're having sex
typically on the moment itself no dude
sex is kind of empowering big thoughts
time for you
you're going down on a new guy
but he's just not into it
you just call it try to switch it up or
keep going
[Laughter]
no offense to any homosexuals out there
that are watching this but this is funny
for us this is funny for us
uh so you want to give him a surprise in
the bedroom
how often do you have how do you
initiate
always sometimes or never
um
all of those answers oh oh oh last one
in bed you
are the moment pretty quiet very loud
i don't know if you are asleep
which goes
very loud it's doing some very complex
calculations i'm pretty mean to yourself
dear miranda is that miranda oh no
that's not that's uh have a priority as
your own you'll find the sex is more
intense and better for you both stop
being so selfish in bed yeah dude thanks
cosmo
it says delays resulting from a fire in
the facility what happened are you
saying your package actually burnt up in
that fire and they had to i don't know
it just says there was a fire at the
facility where the package was as soon
as we're permitted to access the
facility we initiated additional
recovery and repair efforts it's
probably burnt
i don't know
what's happening
the doorbell rang oh that's a middle man
[Applause]
[Music]
your name on it yes
i thought this burnt up in a fire
did you get it yeah
how is that a camera that can fit a baby
you got it yes
i think it needs a lens on there i will
walk 500.
why i don't have a boyfriend quiz
why was i what do you do when you see
the hot soccer player who scored
yesterday's winning goal
i have smile look away
when it comes to relationships you
consider yourself i'm experienced guys
when you're crushing hard on someone new
it's a big deal yeah like i'm kind of
focused your older sister takes you to a
party wait i'm not an only child college
and cutie catches your eye
you fly oh at a college yeah i i people
watch a lot remember i'm focused how
dateable are your are the people at your
school there's some of them out there
that break my focus okay what do you
write in your crush's yearbook oh snap
this is a big one yeah this is kind of a
big one
can you like write in your own answer
here dude are you that desperate you're
gonna write your phone number
let them come to you oh wow yeah
nick this is wait so you know what
you've already already discussed why
you're good in bed okay we're not i'd
actually do a flirty note you have plans
to hang out with girls on friday night
but crush calls
what do you do
i would forget about my friends
the hardest part about having the crush
is
listen
great i'm gonna go with the bottom one
all right too nervous to tell them how
you feel here we go you're shy oh you're
single because you're shy next time a
cutie catches your eye flash that great
smile of yours and say hi thanks to
google auto complete we've figured out
why i'm ugly why nick is bad in bed i'm
great in bed what are you talking about
you're too selfish in bed yeah exactly
that's exactly why he's bad
and why carmichael is single yep comment
below and tell us what you'd like us to
quiz ourselves yeah i'd actually like to
start problem solving this way
will my
daughter
like
knives
benefits of letting kids use knives
wellness mama
tyler with knives free-range kids hey
jake do you raise your kid free range
[Music]
are they are they cageless
last night after i got the camera and
the lenses brett and i just went down to
the liquor store and just got some like
test shots you live with brett so i was
testing out the 24 millimeter and the 85
just because i could only hold two
lenses i just wanted to shoot stuff you
barely colored it you said yeah i mean i
just threw a light on there and
increased the saturation a little bit
but dude i am i'm very impressed so cmx
and i were talking and we were watching
test footage from these rokinon lenses a
big complaint that a lot of people had
about them was that they looked kind of
soft the thing is with the a7s it's such
a sharp camera that having a soft lens
sometimes and having little
imperfections and like little flares you
can kind of meet somewhere in the middle
it makes it almost look more like a film
camera like a gritty look which i really
like personally it all comes down to
what you personally like on the movie ex
machina the dp talks about because the
sony sensors are so sharp he uses old
imperfect broken anamorphic lenses yeah
it still has that that texture that real
texture that you can get in there let's
just cut to this shot like that shot is
score that's a hollywood number one shot
um this looks really good it's a very
cinematic look it's not like the log
flatness that you get like a lot of
people think log footage looks great
because that's pro and it's like that's
not the case this is different i did
shoot s-log on this right but like
there's still contrast there it looks
more cinematic than what i'm trying to
say is that logan it is it's a logan
poster you're just lit by the logan post
split by logan like if you want to shoot
something using only natural light you
got to shoot with the a7s test one
successful dude i want to see what this
looks like in complete darkness
next time on salmon eco subscribe for
more
you are a [ __ ] and i hate you [ __ ]
why would they write that you need some
more adjectives your mom's super hot in
a weird old lady kind of way i hate you
you fatty
your wife is so pretty too bad she is
pakistanian